thanks for joining us America Tory is
with us in Cleveland Ohio hi Tory how
are you hi Dave how are you doing better
than I deserve what's up in your world
well I'm preparing for separation and
I'm not quite sure what to do with my
debt
specifically my student loan debt okay a
separation from your husband or you John
I'm sorry but yes for my husband okay
and so you're preparing for a separation
how long have y'all been married about
22 years oh my goodness it must be bad
it's just that we are just not on the
same page anymore
and with other things but with money as
well and it's just it's just something I
just I just don't want to go on with
have you guys been seeing a marriage
counselor that's something he's not
willing to do
have you gone no okay please do that for
you even if he won't go okay I think it
will give you good emotional information
22 years is a long time and you need to
have somebody walk with you who's not in
the fog if you go through this and or
give you some maybe maybe give you some
information to give him a little bit of
a wake-up call as well but back to your
original question I have a friend of
mine that teaches divorce recovery
recovery after a divorce and I remember
many years ago hearing her say divorce
turns a marriage into a business
transaction and so it comes it's real
quickly the emotions are carved off and
set over to one side
and the actual technical legal financial
details are on the other side and it
becomes a very transactional kind of
thing at that point does that make sense
yes and so here's a couple of things to
look at your student loans are your
student loans they're going to go with
you unless you know you may or may not
get alimony child support or something
else but your student loans are going to
go with you and you're going to have to
pay them so what is your personal income
fifty thousand okay all right and so
what you start doing is if this is a
direction that you know after seeing a
counselor and doing everything you can
to save a 22-year investment and with
all the help you can get you start
preparing for living on your own for
fifty thousand bucks a year and you look
at your student loans how much don't
loaned out have you got are you going to
kill me
hundred sixty thousand oh my lord
okay well how would let them know that
this is going on hardship deferral until
you get past what else whatever else is
going on here okay now do you all own a
home yeah what's it worth two hundred
thousand what's owed on it one hundred
and seventy thousand okay so no equity
there don't mount anything all right
is your car paid for yeah is his car
paid for
no okay is your name on that loan no
good okay are there any credit cards
that have both of your names on them
there is one but I refuse to let him use
it I'm sorry
oh you refuse to let him use it no
better than that glue closed that
account today just completely closed the
credit card if he has the number he can
use it if he's one of the users on the
car here yeah and if things go sideways
emotionally inside your house I have run
into situations and thirty years of
doing this where somebody takes a Mexico
trip and puts it on the card
and you don't want to pay for a $5,000
cruise for somebody else you know and
it'll end up on this card so close the
account today just completely shut it
down it's a zero balance yes good close
it okay
does your checking account have both
names on it no okay so your money is
separated by March is there any other
debt or debt instrument that's open that
as both of your names on it no no okay
I don't accept your mortgage probably as
both your names on it okay so here's
what happens you can't afford to keep
this house you can't stay there you know
so the house that needs to either be
refinanced to get your name off of the
mortgage or sold you cannot stay on the
mortgage and give him the house that
would be dumb and people often do that
in a divorce they often do that but just
you know the negotiation is the car is
in his name he keeps his car your car is
in your name you keep your car your
checking accounts are already separated
there's no other debt you get your
student loan debt it does he have any
big savings or investments or to you and
401ks not big know how much I have I
have 10,000 or 1k and I'm not sure what
he has but I'm thinking it's about five
or six thousand not much at all okay
what is his income it's around ninety
thousand okay in most states your
attorney would have to advise you but in
most states you would be do some alimony
after 22 years and that will going with
your fifty thousand is how you will
reset your life and stay out of debt and
start working your way through these
student loans that are outrageous and
they're going to take you some time to
work through but you're going to be
working extra job you're going to be
doing everything else taking any money
you can squeeze out of your budget and
you are not going to Mexico you've got a
mess on your hands okay so unless it's
to escape no just kidding
but the you know you're gonna be on
beans and rice rice and beans you're
gonna get the cheapest apartment you can
get you're going to stay debt-free and
address these student loans as soon as
you can get stabilized after the
separation which will lead to a divorce
unless it leads to you all getting back
together okay but you prepare for
separation in the same way financially
you would prepare for a divorce and that
puts you in a position of strength to
negotiate in the divorce financially and
that's something that you'll have to do
and your attorney and you get
representation and you'll be ready to
pay them pile up money for deposits and
for paying them don't pay extra on the
student loans until you get the other
side of this and I just put them on
hardship referral and pay nothing right
now but let's get the other side of this
but my hope is is that you guys you can
see a counselor who can give you some
words to say some tools to give Bubba a
wake up call maybe the two of you sit
down with a coach a counselor and walk
you through turning the corner on all of
this before you get so far around the
corner we can't get you back and maybe
you can save this thing that would be
best for everybody involved assuming the
issues that you have that are causing
you such concern or addressed and I'm
sure that sounds like it's a pretty long
list but is it I don't address them see
a counselor for your sake call your
pastor say who can I sit down with it
can walk me through the right questions
to ask myself the right questions to ask
him because he may think you're kidding
he may think you're bluffing and when
you actually move out it may it may wake
him up and he may be willing to work on
that list at that point I don't know but
those kinds of things are best guided by
a really good marriage counselor
that's really experienced and wise and
godly counsel will help you in that
situation and I sure hope you guys can
turn that around that would be my hope
for you it'd be better for all of you
financially as well as everything else
so good question thank you for joining
us hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]